يتنقل دكتور عبد الرازق متاني الخبير في
الاثار والعماره الاسلاميه بين القرى
الفلسطينيه المهجر اهلها داخل الخط الاخضر
وتكشف جولاته ومسوحاته الهندسيه عن تشققات
وانهيارات في مساجد وكنائس ومعالم اثريه
اضحت انظروا بخطر انهيارها واندثارها ولا
تنحصر الاسباب في امر الاعتداء عليها
وانتهاك حرماتها فحسب بل تتعدى ذلك الى
عوامل الطبيعه والهزات الارضيه التي فاقمت
الصدوعه والشقوق فيها الى ما نتحدث عن
مباني مثل هذه المباني لا ترمم لا يحافظ
عليها وضع خطير الحجاره والاسمنت يتساقط
من بين الحجاره فهي اصبحت معرضه اكثر
للانهيار بسبب الزلازل وايضا بسبب العوامل
الطبيعيه بسبب الامطار بسبب العواصف
تكشف المعطيات والمخططات الهندسيه الجديده
تدهور حال هذه المقدسات من سيء الى اسوا
وتحضر اسرائيل على الفلسطينيين ترميم هذه
الشواهد الداله على وجودهم في قراهم التي
هجروا منها وتغلق معظمها وتهمل ترميمها
نحن خرجنا قبل فتره بفكره اقامه الهيئه
الوطنيه لحمايه الاوقاف الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه واضح انه كان في نشاطات في
السابق للحركه الاسلاميه بمسح مناطق معينه
هذا الموضوع بحاجه الى استكمال
وتقدير للجهد الذي حصل في كل الاحوال هذا
موضوع يعني نراه في صلب حياتنا وصلب عملنا
من اجل ان نؤكد على هويت هذا البلد خلال
النكبه دمرت العصابات الصهيونيه ما يزيد
على 500 قريه وبلده فلسطينيه واقامت على
انقاضها اسرائيل واليوم يعيش نحو ثلاثمائه
الف مهجر من اهلها في بلدات قريبه من
قراهم المدمره ولا تسمح اسرائيل لهم
بالعوده اليها رغم انهم اصبحوا مواطنين
فيها
هي ليست مجرده اطلال او حجاره صماء بل
بقايا وطن كان ينبض بالحياه قبل النكمه
يقول الفلسطينيون انهم لن يفرطوا بهذه
المعالم فهي الشاهد على وجودهم في هذه
الارض وسند حقهم بالعوده اليها ليسكن
الجزيره من قريه النبي يوشع المهجره قضاء
صفد